thousands of supporters lined up in
front of this gym next to rio de
janeiro's iconic maracana football
stadium
inside crowds wearing the colors of the
brazilian flag cheer for president
shaibo sonaru calling him the messiah
and the myth
bolsonaro's wife michelle an evangelical
christian spoke first she made an
emotional appeal especially to women
given the president needs more of their
votes if he's going to be returned to
the top job she reminded them of the
attempt on bolsonaro's life during the
2018 campaign
saying he'd survive to free the country
[Applause]
i always tell him
bolsonaro do not be afraid you have been
chosen by god bolsonaro then spoke but
made no reference to guns or his
unfounded accusations that the
electronic voting system is unreliable
he has been criticized in brazil and
abroad for repeatedly claiming that the
october elections could be easily rigged
experts say he is following former u.s
president donald trump by alleging fraud
to justify what may become an eventual
defeat bolsonaro's supporters here are
extremely confident that he will be
re-elected
but polls show him trailing behind
former president luiz inacio lula da
silva
earlier this week former president lula
da silva was officially nominated
candidate by the left-wing workers party
according to recent polls he has the
support of more than 40 percent of
voters
bolsonaro remains in second place with
more than 30 percent but it's too soon
to predict an outcome as bolsonaro has
just approved an emergency aid package
allowing him to spend 7.6 billion
dollars until december when his term
ends mauna kea
al-jazeera rio de janeiro
[Music]